-It is great to see you.
We love it when you come by.
Always looking good, bud.
-I love being here, man.
-Always a stud.
By the way, speaking of studs,
look at this cover of "Esquire."
If anyone saw this.
Look at this.
Hey, that's what
I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, just wait.
And I think you know
what photo I'm going to show.
I'm reading about ya.
I go, "Oh, cool, I saw."
And then we had the page marked
and blocked off as well because.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is going through your mind
when you go,
"Oh, maybe I'll try this?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I was a fan of the photo.
It was inspired by the
Red Hot Chili Peppers.
I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the photo.
But they used to put on shows
wearing just only a sock
all the time.
And, you know, I just wanted
something kind of
like shocking for this cover.
-You got it.
I want to talk about
also the album, by the way.
We have to talk about this.
I love the cover art right here.
Gorgeous.
But also you were in a movie
earlier this year called "X."
-Yeah.
-And I know that your mom is
a giant fan of your stuff,
and you go,
"Well, maybe, Mom, you can't see
this one."
-Yeah, this one I was like,
"No, you can't."
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, the "Esquire" picture
is nothing.
-No. I mean, she's seen
"Esquire,"
but I don't know what she thinks
about that one photo.
She kind of just like didn't say
anything about it.
-This is the one thing
that she can't see.
You go, "Here's the movie, Mom,
but you can't see this.
Just trust me, it's good."
-Yeah, yeah.
But she was hearing all these
good things about it and,
you know, she was just like,
"Man, I want to see it."
And I was, like, "Well, let me
hit up Ti West and see if
it's possible to make like
a mommy edit of the movie..."
[ Laughter ]
..."that has no sex included
at all
and it's just nothing
but gore and madness."
So he said, "Let me see
what I can do."
And he hit me up two days later,
and he was like,
"What's your mom's address? I'm
going to send it to her house."
-No way.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So he really made a mom edit
just for you?
-He made a mommy edit.
I call it the mommy edit.
-That's a good man.
That's a good dude right there.
I'd never heard the word
"Entergalactic"
before as one word.
But you were telling me
backstage, you go,
"Yeah, I think I actually
created a different language
as well with my daughter."
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And I go,
"What are you talking about?"
You showed me this.
And it's very interesting.
Do you have a name
for the language yet?
-No, not yet.
-No, because it's just starting
really.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's like meeping almost.
-Yeah, kind of like Road Runner.
-Yeah, meep, like "meep, meep."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So it just started with what?
How did this start meeping?
-I send my daughter
silly messages all the time.
Sometimes I'll just send her
voice notes where I'm like...
[ Shouting gibberish ]
For no reason.
-Sounds like a goat in pain.
-And she's just like,
"Hi, Daddy." You know?
But I was like, "Man, I just
want to send her something.
I just want to play with her and
see if she can pick up on it."
And I sent "Meep, meep."
And she responded like, "Meep."
And I was like, "Oh, I got her,
I got her."
So I kept going with it.
I was like, "Meep, meep morpus."
And then she responded,
"Meep, meep, morpus, morpus."
And I was like, "Okay, okay.
Let me spice it up
a little bit."
I sent, "Meep meeps poos.
Meeps poopis morpus."
[ Laughter ]
Meaning like, I [bleep]
my pants.
-Okay, alright.
Again, we're going to have to
edit a lot of things
for your mom.
[ Laughter ]
This is the thing.
This is actually a text from you
and your daughter.
-Yeah.
-So this "mi meep--"
-"Meep meep merp merp meep.
Mi meeps mu muu."
Because I say "mi meeps mu."
That's "I love you."
And she says, "I love you too."
And then thanks -- "muu meeps."
And she says, "mo mulem."
[ Laughter ]
-"Mo mulem,"
you're welcome, yeah.
Mi mi -- Mi mi meepies,
which I think means very funny.
[ Laughter ]
Let's talk about
"Entergalactic," please.
This is your 10th studio album.
It comes out on Friday.
Also your TV special
"Entergalactic"
is on Netflix Friday.
How do these projects about
and which one came first?
-Well, the music came first.
I was kind of like bored of
doing the same old thing
with albums, like kind of
releasing an album,
doing two or three music videos
tops
and then that'd be
the end of it.
I wanted something,
just a bigger splash this time
around, you know?
And I thought about the idea
to splice the music
with the animation but have the
music kind of narrate the story.
You know, something that hasn't
really been done before.
-Yeah.
-You know?
And that's kind of why we've
been calling it a TV event.
-You're always doing something
different.
I love that you just keep going,
something else different.
-I try to push it.
I always try to push it.
-Yeah, and you got some good
friends that come in
and do voices in this special.
-Yeah, yeah.
I just reached out to people
that I knew,
people that I love and see if
they would do a favor for me.
-I mean, Timothee Chalamet
is in it.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's fun.
You just call him and say,
"Timothee, let's do this."
-Yeah, I was talking to him
about it,
and he said it sounded cool.
And over the years, when things
started to pick up, I was like,
"Hey, man, you're going to get
an offer
one day to do this show.
I was serious about you
doing this."
And he's like, "No, I'm serious.
I want to do it."
-So he did it.
-And he got the scripts.
We sent him everything.
He loved it.
'Cause that's the thing, you
know -- I never want my friends
to feel like I'm going to lead
them into some bull[bleep].
I kind of wanted to let them
know like, "This is dope."
-"You can trust me."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"-I'm going to make it cool.
I'll make it look good."
Can you explain the story about
the Netflix special?
-Well, pretty much it's about --
it starts with this guy, Jabari,
who just moved into his
apartment and got a new job
working at this comic book
company
to develop his character
into a comic book.
And he meets this young lady,
Meadow, who ends up
being his neighbor down the hall
from him.
And he has, like, this instant
connection with her.
And the show is pretty much
about their relationship,
and will they or won't they,
you know?
-Yeah, I want to show everyone
a clip.
Here's Kid Cudi in his Netflix
special "Entergalactic."
Take a look at this.
-What's up?
-Right.
Uh, so I just want to apologize
for last night.
I feel so bad.
I did not mean for things to get
so out of control.
-It's all good. All good.
I can't be mad at a Friday night
turn-up.
But I can be mad at your music.
-Uh, I'm sorry?
-Yeah. Was that Drew Hill?
-Okay, pre-"Thong Song" Sisqo
was fire.
-Yeah, but never forget
post-"Thong Song" Sisqo.
-Fair.
-Post-"Thong Song."
♪ Thong, thong,
thong, thong, thong ♪
-Hold on, man.
We love Sisqo. We love Sisqo.
Don't get it twisted.
-Yeah, don't get it twisted.
Kid Cudi, everybody.
"Entergalactic" is on Netflix
this Friday.
His new album "Entergalactic"
is also out Friday.
When we come back, he's
performing with Ty Dolla $ign.
Kid Cudi!